From a terrifying Romanian abbey to a murderous
occultist in Connecticut, the story told through
the Conjuring movies spans decades.
Here's how all the pieces fit together.
Chronologically speaking, the Conjuring Universe
all starts with "The Nun."
Released in 2018, this film takes place in
1952, at the Abbey of St. Carta in Romania.
Father Burke and a novitiate, Sister Irene,
have been dispatched by the Vatican to investigate
the suicide of one of the abbey's nuns.
After a bit of research, they discover the
nuns have been spending most of their time
praying in shifts to keep a nun-shaped evil
entity from hitchhiking its way out into the
real world on a human host.
As it turns out, the abbey was originally
built by a duke during the Middle Ages who
was more interested in demon worship than
Catholicism.
He managed to raise the demon Valak but was
stopped by a group of Christian knights who
were able to seal Valak, at least temporarily.
With the help of a nice local man named Frenchie,
Father Burke and Sister Irene finally banish
Valak back to Hell, thanks to an ancient artifact
filled with the blood of Jesus Christ.
"You should have kept running when you had
the chance, Frenchman."
"I'm French-Canadian."
Or, at least, they think they've beaten the
demon.
But as it happens, Valak manages to hitch
a supernatural ride out of town on Frenchie's back.
The Valak character in the Conjuring Universe
may have taken its inspiration from a demon
with a slightly different name described in
Aleister Crowley's "The Lesser Key of Solomon"
as a "child with angel's wings riding on a
two-headed dragon."
The Conjuring Universe version of Valak is
clearly not a child, and it doesn't have angel's wings.
Whether or not it rides a two-headed dragon
is up for some debate, since who's to say
that the dragon didn't get left behind when
Valak crossed over from Hell.
One very specific thing that's mentioned in
both mythologies, however, is their connection to snakes.
Like Crowley's demon, who's known "to tell
where serpents may be seen," the Valak of
the 1950s Romanian monastery has its own tie
to the biblical reptile, along with a much
more impressive title:
"The Defiler, the Profane, the Marquis of
Snakes."
As fans of the franchise know, Valak goes
on to become a major recurring villain in
the story of the Conjuring Universe.
"The Nun II" picks up only a few years later
in 1956, as Sister Irene hides out in Italy
following her battle with Valak.
But, after catching wind of a mysterious series
of deaths, not to mention an eerie vision
of a distressed Frenchie, the nun gets permission
to investigate these bizarre happenings.
Sadly, Father Burke has passed away, but joining
Irene this time around is Sister Debra, a
nun who lacks faith.
Of course, this all leads to Valak's triumphant
return.
"What did you see?"
"I saw a nun."
During Sister Irene's investigation, she learns
that Valak is after a Catholic relic, the
eyes of Saint Lucy — a Christian martyr
who was supernaturally kept from burning alive,
a quality her descendants share.
The eyes of Saint Lucy happen to be hidden
in the French boarding school where Frenchie
currently works.
With the help of a young girl named Sophie,
Irene uncovers the relic, which the Valak-possessed
Frenchie takes for himself soon after.
At full strength, Valak attempts but fails
to burn Irene alive, revealing that Irene
is a descendant of St. Lucy herself.
After Sisters Irene and Debra pray fervently,
Valak is seemingly banished back to hell,
and all seems well.
Except it's not: the movie ends with a flash-forward
to Ed and Lorraine Warren receiving an interesting
call, likely teasing Frenchie's inevitable
re-possession, or maybe something even more sinister.
The story of Annabelle the demon doll starts
in 1943 with "Annabelle: Creation," when a
dollmaker named Samuel Mullins and his wife
Esther lose their seven-year-old daughter,
Annabelle, in a freak car accident.
About 12 years later, in 1955, the Mullins
decide they've spent enough time without a
child, so they open their doors to a group
of orphaned girls and the nun tasked with
their care, a woman by the name of Sister
Charlotte.
When one of the orphans, a girl named Janice,
stumbles upon a porcelain doll in a locked
bedroom, she unwittingly releases a demon
that wreaks havoc on the house and its inhabitants.
It's soon revealed that following their daughter's
death, the Mullins had been tricked into letting
a demon take possession of one of Samuel's
dolls, and it's now decided to try and find
a human host.
By the end of the ordeal, the demon has succeeded
in possessing Janice, who escapes and — now
going by the name Annabelle — winds up being
adopted by a nice family in Santa Monica,
where she grows up, runs away, joins a cult,
and then returns to murder her adoptive parents
in 1967.
Talk about a downbeat ending.
"So, which one of you gets this?"
As it turns out, the nice family that adopted
Annabelle lives next door to John and Mia
Form, the main protagonists of 2014's "Annabelle."
John has given his wife Mia an antique porcelain
doll as a gift for their unborn child.
But after Janice-slash-Annabelle and her boyfriend
kill her parents, they move on to the Form
residence, where Annabelle takes a sudden
and deadly liking to Mia's antique.
"I like your dolls."
During the struggle, she takes her own life
and transfers the demon back into its original home.
Terror sets in as the demon doll decides that
Mia would make a nice soul sacrifice.
The couple is helped by a local bookseller
named Evelyn and their parish priest, Father
Perez, the latter of whom tries to take the
doll to Ed and Lorraine Warren, but is attacked
before he has the chance.
Willing to sacrifice her own soul to save
her newborn daughter, Mia tries to jump out
of her window with the doll.
Luckily, John and Evelyn arrive in time to
stop her, and Evelyn takes the doll ... and
Mia's place.
"There has to be another way."
"There is.
I can make it right."
In the end, an unsuspecting woman buys the
doll from a toyshop as a gift for her daughter,
a nurse.
Here's where we finally get our first proper
introduction to Ed and Lorraine Warren in 1968.
That nurse, whose mother had given her a very
hideous doll as a present, is now at the mercy
of the demon spirit trapped inside the toy,
and she needs the Warrens' help in exorcizing
the thing.
So the Warrens take the doll off the nurse's
hands and move on to their next case.
In 1971 in Wakefield, the Warrens are teaching
a class on demonology at Massachusetts Western University.
One of the attendees at the Warrens' demonology
lecture is Carolyn Perron, a wife and mother
whose family has recently moved into a Rhode
Island farmhouse.
And unfortunately, they're now being tormented
by a malevolent, clap-happy spirit.
"Give me the third clap."
But it's not all fun and games when it comes
to this hellspawn.
After some digging, the Warrens discover the
house was built on land that once belonged
to a witch named Bathsheba, who sacrificed
her week-old child to the devil before hanging
herself, and then spent the following century
possessing and killing future residents.
Ed and Lorraine suggest the family move into
a motel temporarily, while they try to get
the Catholic Church to agree to an exorcism.
But Bathsheba has already set her sights on
Carolyn, and the now-possessed mother brings
her kids back to the house to kill them.
The Warrens show up in time for Ed to perform
a rogue exorcism on his own, and the curse
of Bathsheba is lifted, leaving the Perrons
with a livable farmhouse and the Warrens free
to move on to a new case.
A year after all that, in 1972, When Ed and
Lorraine Warren are needed on an overnight
investigation, they hire a teenager named
Mary Ellen to babysit their daughter Judy.
This turns out to be a terrible decision.
Not only do the Warrens at this point in time
have an entire room devoted to possessed objects
in their home, but Mary Ellen has a friend
named Daniela who really wants to speak to
her dead father.
Daniela drops by the house uninvited and does
what any girl in her position would do.
She finds a way into the Warrens' artifact
room, disturbs Annabelle, and unleashes every
ghost and demon the Warrens have trapped in
their basement.
"It's the doll, Ed.
It's a beacon for other spirits."
Understanding that, the three girls set about
trying to get the doll back in her glass prison,
hoping that will stop the haunting.
The girls spend the night essentially playing
hide and seek with a bunch of possessed objects
before Annabelle is returned to her case once
and for all.
Valak makes its return in 2016's "The Conjuring
2," the film that sees Ed and Lorraine Warren
finally defeat the Marquis of Snakes…maybe.
Beginning in 1976, the couple is investigating
the infamous Amityville murders, and Lorraine
has a vision where one of the murdered DeFeo
children leads her to the basement, and she
comes face to face with Valak and a vision
of her husband's death.
Lorraine continues to see visions of the demon
nun, even as the pair travel to Enfield, England,
where the Hodgson family has been experiencing
paranormal activity.
When it appears as though the entire haunting
is a hoax put on by the family to gain fame,
the Warrens pack up their things to leave.
But Lorraine soon realizes that Valak has
been behind the entire thing, and they return
to the house in a last ditch effort to save
the eldest daughter, Janet, who at this point
is possessed and trying to jump out a window.
Ed grabs her, but almost falls to his death
in the process, leaving Lorraine to go head
to head with Valak herself.
She succeeds in banishing the demon by using
its name and pulls Ed to safety.
"I condemn you back to heeeeeell."
Close call!
A few years later, in 1981, the Warrens document
the exorcism of a young boy named David Glatzel.
Unfortunately, the evil spirit in David overpowers
Ed and makes a deal with Arne Johnson, the
young man dating David's older sister Debbie.
Arne offers himself up in David's place, and
the demon accepts.
Though Ed sees this happen, he loses consciousness
for over a month, giving the demon-possessed
Arne just enough time to murder his landlord.
Eventually, Ed and Lorraine learn that David
was possessed only after first being cursed
by an object built by Isla the Occultist.
This leads them to Father Kastner, a retired
priest who has previously dealt with a cult
called the Disciples of the Ram.
It turns out that he's also the secret father
of Isla, who he accidentally exposed to occult practices.
To save Arne, the Warrens destroy the altar
that Isla built, expelling the demon before
it can do any more damage.
Unfortunately for Isla, the demon returns
to its former master, killing the Occultist
and dragging her soul to Hell.
Ed and Lorraine's story isn't done just yet.
A fourth "Conjuring" film, titled "The Conjuring:
Last Rites," is currently in development,
with Patrick Wilson and Vera Farmiga returning
as everyone's favorite paranormal investigators.
Produced once more by James Wan and Peter
Safran, "Last Rites" looks like it could potentially
be Ed and Lorraine's final Conjuring Universe
adventure.
No matter how it plays out, it'll be great
to see them tackle the forces of evil yet again.
Additionally, a Conjuring Universe TV series
is also in the works at Max, which may be
another spooky avenue for the Warrens' most
hideous adversaries to rear their ugly heads.
Given how early in development the series
is, we don't have many details.
In fact, you could say we have nun.